should be here
okay
uh
am in the right space
hi everyone
okay happy wednesday
feels like it should be later than
wednesday in the week it may be the only
one feels that way okay
a couple of items for you all at the top
today the department of treasury
announced the establishment of a new
department the office of recovery
programs
to lead the treasury department's
implementation of economic relief and
recovery programs
including nearly 420 billion dollars in
programs from the american rescue plan
this new office which will be led by the
inaugural chief recovery officer
jacob liebenluft will be focused on
efficiently establishing and
administering treasury's programs to
support an
equitable and swift recovery from the
economic challenges brought on by the
covet 19
pandemic jacob will also serve as the ed
will serve as the lead administrator of
recovery programs and a principal
advisor
on recovery program implementation and
he of course will work closely with gene
sperling another piece of good news
today the irs the use department of
treasury and the bureau of fiscal
service announced that they are
dispersing nearly two million
dollar million payments from the
american rescue plan
which brings the total disburse so far
to approximately 159 million payments
with a total value of more than 376
billion dollars
since these payments began rolling out
just last month
over 320 000 payments worth 450 million
into veterans affairs beneficiaries who
received the va
benefits but don't normally file the tax
return and didn't use the non-filer's
tool last year hence it took
a little bit longer these payments also
include social security beneficiaries
who didn't file a 2020 or 2019 tax
return
and the latest batch of payments has a
total value of more than 3.4
billion finally yesterday microsoft
issued new
patches for additional vulnerabilities
found in its exchange servers you all
remember the
the hacking that we talked about just a
few
weeks ago the white house urges all
systems operators to
apply these patches as soon as possible
to ensure the security of systems
the federal government takes this
vulnerability very seriously
we're leading by example and requiring
all federal agencies to apply these
patches
and report to the cyber security and
infrastructure security agency
that alex thanks jen um can you talk a
little bit about the
uh april 28th address to congress what
we should expect to hear from the
president and also
logistically we know that the attendance
will be reduced
so how are you deciding who gets to
attend um and then are you working with
capital
police on security or are you monitoring
any potential threats at this point
sure well on the second and third
question um we have of course are
working very closely with the speaker's
office
with the offices of leaders in congress
uh the president
was uh is looking forward to uh
it look is excited to have accepted
their invitation to address a joint
session something that he has been eager
to do
since he uh was inaugurated in terms of
a preview of what the speech will look
like we're just
we're a couple weeks out for that so i
expect we'll have more to say as we get
closer
but certainly you can expect that he
will talk about
all of the priorities and his commitment
to building the economy back better
getting the pandemic under control
addressing the challenges we face around
the world
but as we get closer and the speeches
written we'll have more of a preview
in terms of invitations um that
certainly would be
uh handled by the speaker's office and
so i'd point you to them
sure and then on afghanistan the
intelligence community's
annual report this year said and i'm
quoting
the afghan government will struggle to
hold the taliban at bay if the coalition
withdraws its support
so what plans does the administration
have to prevent this from happening and
to maintain stability in the region
with that withdrawal and then is there a
potential for president biden to change
his mind or extend the deadline if there
is a decline in the situation
in afghanistan in the coming months well
first let me say that as a part of this
process
the president asked for a review from
his national security
team he asked them not to sugarcoat it
he welcomed ideas
welcomed differences of points of view
and he was provided with a clear-eyed
assessment about the best path forward
so as a part of his assessment and
decision making
uh you know part of the discussion was
around the fact that the terrorist
threat has evolved
and we certainly saw the threat
assessment and saw our colleagues
testify yesterday
but part of what we have seen from the
intelligence community also is that
the threat has just become more
dispersed it's metastasized around the
world
al-shabab and somalia al-qaeda and the
arabian peninsula
al-nusra and syria it's changed we're
not looking at the 2001
um mindset we can't look at things
through the 2001 mindset we have to look
at things through the 2021
world so we will be monitoring our
administration our
national security teams in partnership
with our nato allies
and partners in the region we will be
monitoring of course
and disrupting um and focused on
disrupting terrorist networks and
operations uh that have spread far
beyond afghanistan but also continuing
to monitor things in the region we're
not going to take our threat
off of the terrorist threat take our
eyes off sorry the terrorist threat or
any sign of al qaeda's
resurgence and we will reposition our
counterterrorism
capabilities uh in in that regard and
the president will talk more about that
in his speech in about an hour and a
half
deadline extent or could he change his
mind if you do see
the situation in afghanistan decline
well i will say that the president made
this decision after close consultations
and uh close discussion with and taking
under uh
under uh into account uh all of the um
all of the difficult decisions uh all
the difficult factors i should say
around that decision so i know he
remains committed to the uh timeline
that he
intends to set out in the speech and one
more quick one on immigration uh vice
president harris just said that her
first trip abroad and it looks like it's
going to be in mexico in guatemala but
she
suggested she won't be visiting the
border um and so i'm wondering
first off if the president is
considering a trip to the border
and second why it's not important for
one of
you know the president's main uh sort of
people that he's he's tasked with
dealing with this to visit the border
well what the president's asked the vice
president to do is run points on the
northern triangle
and be a a high-level conduit
in having discussions with leaders in
the region that's exactly what
she is doing and will do when she goes
and visits
countries in the region and it and
obviously she's had discussions that
have been read out as well with some
leaders in the region
uh secretary of homeland security has
visited the border our secretary
other secretaries who run points on
these issues will and we expect will in
the future i don't have any
visits to preview for you of the
presidents but his focus is on
solutions is on opening up additional
facilities
which we have done a great deal of in
the last couple of weeks
on moving kids out of the border patrol
facilities as quickly as possible into
these shelters which we've seen
some progress on in the numbers that
have been released by the department of
homeland security
that's where his focus is on i expect
other
senior officials cabinet members who are
running point will continue to
do visits and and come back and report
back to the president go ahead stephen
was there a unanimous view among the
president's national security advisers
that now
is the time to leave afghanistan well
steve i
will leave it to them to speak to their
viewpoints but i will
again um reassert that uh the president
asked for uh a review he asked for that
review not to be sugar-coated
uh he wanted to hear different points of
views he welcomed
debate and ultimately he made the
decision that because
the terrorist threat has evolved because
we have done exactly what we said we
would do
when we went to afghanistan to deliver
justice to those who attacked us on
september 11th
because he believes that the more that
that more time does not
does would not result in a military
solution that now is the time to leave
you saw where the cia director said the
us government's ability to collect
and act on threats will diminish when
the time comes from the u.s military to
withdraw
does that give you pause at all
does it give us pause that the threat
okay obviously uh uh
the cia director uh bill burns is
somebody who the president
takes advice from takes counsel from and
certainly listens to
when he shares uh his point of view uh
and he's known him for quite some time
but i will again reiterate that uh
he would say and many of our
intelligence officials have said
publicly and in these hearings that
the threats have evolved that we need to
approach
uh how we look at counter terrorism
through the prism of what the threats
are in 2021
and even if you look at al-qaeda it is
not uh
it is not being harbored in a safe haven
in afghanistan how it was
20 years ago we have to have resources
we have to have assets to address the
threat
where we see it growing and that is in
places like northern africa
in the arabian peninsula and even if you
just look at the counter-terrorism
component of it
we need to make decisions through the
2021 prism
actually just separately the kremlin is
saying the uh the summit the proposed
summit that the president proposed
would be contingent on u.s behavior what
what is your response to that and i know
you have some sanctions in the
in the works here well you'll have to
ask them what they meant by that i know
they
are uh verbose in their thoughts on the
united states so they may have an answer
to your question
i will say uh that the president uh
president biden i should say had a
constructive call
yesterday uh as is the case in uh his
relationships with
uh countries where we have had difficult
discussions where we need to have
difficult discussions he did not hold
back on his concerns including
reiterating that there will be
consequences to the actions that were
taken
i expect you will know more about that
soon at the same time
our objective as the united states is to
have a predictable relationship with
russia
to stabilize that relationship and
certainly having a discussion
having a summit uh would be an
opportunity to discuss areas where we
agree and can work together whether it's
a continuation of non-proliferation
efforts
uh obviously they're a partner in the p5
plus one and those could be
part of the forum for a discussion go
ahead
um following up a little bit on alex
with the odni global threats report
if this wasn't sugar coated to the
president then clearly he's aware of the
possibility that kabul could fall at
some point in the next couple of years
without
u.s and coalition support should we uh
read into this decision that that he's
decided that through the scope of
the global threats he's facing he's
looking at right now that is an
acceptable consequence
if the u.s is to pursue his priorities
or the changing threat landscape
i think you should look at it through
the prism of the president assessing
what's in the national interests of the
united states
and from his vantage point we
did exactly what we intended to do we
delivered the
justice to those who attacked us on
september 11th we disrupted
terrorists seeking to use afghanistan as
a safe haven
to attack the united states but he also
believes there is not a military
solution
this will require a diplomatic solution
and even as we are withdrawing our
troops
we will continue to support diplomatic
and humanitarian work
we will ask other countries to step up
whether that's pakistan
russia china india turkey countries in
the region that certainly have a stake
in stability
we will continue to provide significant
humanitarian resources
so we are we will continue to be engaged
this is the president's assessment about
whether having
troops on the ground a military presence
in the same way
in a version of the same way it has been
over the last two decades
is in our national interest and he made
the decision it is not
another one an apologies if i missed
this on briefing calls
but with the removal of combat troops by
september 11th with the latest
does that include special operators
special forces uh
any those types of troops on the ground
well i'm obviously not going to get into
operational specifics
um from the podium i will say that
we may we we will have what is needed to
secure a diplomatic presence
and those assessments will be made over
the coming months and obviously led by
the defense department of state
department coordination one more on
immigration um
the the outgoing ambassador jacobson
said on friday that
uh to reuters in an interview there was
consideration of conditional cash
payments related to the northern
triangle is that something that's
currently under consideration and so
what are kind of the parameters of what
would be looked at there
that's interesting i'd have to look more
at her context the context of her
comments and i'm happy to do that
i think what we are focused on is
working
directly with these countries to
determine how we can
deter uh travel uh deter
migrants from making the journey and we
made an announcement of course over the
last couple of days
about uh stepped-up personnel at the
border
that these countries are putting in
place to a number of these countries i
should say in the region
are putting in place in order to deter
the journey in order to
uh reduce the number of migrants who are
making it to our border
and certainly we're having discussions
about assistance and how that can be
disseminated and the most effective
and effective i should say an impactful
way but i'd have to check on the context
and see where that's headed
sure go ahead thanks jen republican
senators have criticized attaching
the withdrawal of troops in afghanistan
to september 11th
they say it's politically driven do you
have a response to that and also
do you have anything to share on who
came up with that deadline
and why i think it was uh the president
uh wanting to send a clear message that
this is not going to be an
an open-ended timeline to withdrawing
troops
uh we have had that policy uh for some
time in the past and he disagreed with
it
so he was giving a timeline on when
operationally we could move
troops out we also are going to do that
in close coordination with
uh our nato partners and other countries
in the region if it's ahead of that
timeline
then that's a positive step but we
wanted to give the military and our
diplomatic partners on the ground plenty
of time
did he choose 9 11 as the final i think
i just explained why he chose that
timeline
on iran in a new statement president
rouhani
said that the decision to increase
uranium enrichment
was in direct response to the cyber
attack from israel
has president biden or any other u.s
officials
had a conversation with israel about
refraining from further attacks as he
tries to broker a nuclear deal well
um i would just read it that we don't
have any uh additional speculation to
add to the cause or the origin of the
attacks over the weekend
what our focus is on uh is on the
diplomatic path forward
and we believe in the diplomatic
conversations though they will be
indirect
will reconvene uh tomorrow in vienna we
know this will be a long process but we
certainly see that as a positive sign
and one more go ahead has the president
selected somebody to fill that senior
aapk role
and will that person attend his meeting
with kpec tomorrow
uh we are getting much closer to having
news to share
on uh that high level personnel
announcement i don't expect that person
will be attending tomorrow but
hopefully we'll have more to share soon
go ahead thank you jen
can you explain the rationale for why
president biden went
against the advice of military
commanders who recommended leaving
2 500 troops on the ground in
afghanistan
well i think that's an over
characterization of every military
leader and i don't think they've all
provided their point of view on what
their advice is and we'll keep that
private uh so you can certainly speak to
individuals if you'd like
of course i will say again the president
uh welcomed the advice welcomes at times
disagreement about what the appropriate
path forward should be
but his view based on the assessments of
where our terrorist threat exists today
the fact that it is metastasized that it
has spread into
many other regions of the world that we
can still
uh we still do have the ability to uh
have a presence in the region
where we can keep our eye on the
terrorist threat that it led him to make
to conclude that now is the time for
troops to leave
i think it's important also to note that
uh we have
uh that his view is that we can't
continue the cycle of exp standing or
expanding our military
footprint hoping to create the ideal
conditions for our withdrawal
no one will tell you unless someone has
told you and then tell me that of course
that we should stay forever no military
commander wants to stay forever
they insist that this is not some insist
this is not entire
the time to leave some opponents of his
decision but his view
is that uh we've been having that
argument that argument has been made for
10 years
and it has not changed the outcome has
not made a military solution more
appealing
or more effective so our pentagon team
reports that most
military commanders in the region and i
don't want to give any names because
they don't want to
uh you know violate any on background
agreements but you know they say that
most military
commanders in the region recommended
that 2500 troop level and if you look at
then candidate buying his own comments
from about a year ago he said that he
wanted to leave
several thousand troops in afghanistan
so what changed between now and then
he asked his team for a clear assessment
uh he uh to make a determination about
the best path forward
i will remind everyone that he has been
someone who has
long viewed or this he opposed the surge
in afghanistan
he has long viewed the the presence the
military presence in afghanistan as
something that was not a constructive
long-term solution that has been his
consistent view
at the same time because we have the
ability to
uh have a pres who work with our
partners in the region to
have a presence where we can prevent in
the region to prevent
to allow ourselves to keep an eye on the
terrorist threat uh
he feels this is something that is in
our interest as a country and
now is the time to do it one question
about special immigrant visas for
afghans who really just risk their lives
helping
the us government and the us military
will the president
commit to more visas and expedited
processing
for those combat translators before
pulling out because you know the taliban
uh have already threatened their lives
well he will talk more about this in his
speech
um and more about his commitment to
helping exactly those
uh brave individuals who have served and
helped our troops
and our military presence on the ground
uh go ahead
jen on the russia call you said that the
president did not hold back
in addressing his concerns um but the
kremlin said that
the president did not bring up alexi
navalny
on the call um and is that accurate
uh and if so why didn't he bring
up a very kind of key human rights issue
on the call
well well i don't have more specifics of
the president's
comments to um read out from the call i
will
just say that uh the the status the
health the well-being of lexi navalny is
something that we
raise frequently and through many
channels with the russians and we have
repeatedly called
for an improvement in his treatment for
his release
through through many of those channels
the purpose of this call
was to discuss in part um the
the fact that there will be consequences
to the actions of
uh russian leaders over the past uh
several months back into last year uh
and also to emphasize that and to also
raise i should say
um the our unwavering commitments
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity and concerns about what we see
as aggressive behavior
on the border uh and also to uh lay out
to lay out the possibility of a
meeting uh in order to move toward a
more predictable and stable relationship
so
uh that was the part of the robust
agenda
discussed and i can assure you that the
the health the safety of lexi navalny
has raised frequently and through many
channels
uh go ahead thank you a few questions
the officer who fatally shot dante
wright
resigned does president biden believe
that officers should face charges
i'm not going to weigh in on on
legal or law enforcement actions i will
leave that to the courts and
and law enforcement authorities on the
ground a state trooper
also fatally shot a 16 year old in
maryland this is on top of
the shooting of dante wright under the
obama administration the justice
department had ramped up
investigations of local police
departments
does president biden plan to reinstate
similar pattern and practice
investigations to identify civil rights
and other abuses and training well let
me say first that
uh all of these incidents that we're
seeing you've mentioned some of them are
just a reminder
that too often in this country law
enforcement uses
unnecessary force and too often that
results in the death of black americans
and the president has repeatedly said
that he believes we need police reform
and that's why he's calling on congress
to deliver that to his desk
in terms of actions of the justice
department or investigations
you'd have to ask the attorney general
why has president biden not
issued an executive order to recall
military equipment from
local police departments that was an
expectation that many civil rights
advocates had
in the earlier weeks of this presidency
and we've been in
very close touch with many several civil
rights leaders about their
uh the issues the ideas they have
concerns they have in some cases and
what they'd like to see happen we're
working very closely with them
on moving and pushing for the passage of
the george floyd act i know that does
not solve all of the issues we're not
suggesting that
i would say this is an issue uh that is
uh will be a cause of the
president biden's time in office and we
are less than 100
days in there's more to come right now
our focus is on working toward
getting that legislation passed on a
separate matter
uh the fine administration has issued a
proposal to rescind some of the trump
bureau abortion rules why
is the administration not immediately
suspending those roles
i can check in you're talking about the
title 10 rules there can be a process
sometimes and if it's an agency action
sometimes that's the reasoning i can
check on the specifics of the timeline
but our our point of view is certainly
they should be rescinded so
uh go go ahead thank you again um
i'm back on afghanistan um
diplomatically since that seems to be
the
the solution that the president is going
to lay out what role
does the united states intend to play
after the withdrawal
in talks between the afghan government
and the taliban you mean in direct
engagement
oh well i would leave that in part to
the state department who would be
leading on any diplomatic talks and
conversations we certainly believe that
a diplomatic path is the only path
forward there are conversations that are
convening i think later this week and
there is
uh we do have an envoy who often
participates in those talks and
conversations and i expect that would be
the case moving forward
and secondly um was there any discussion
is the president who's talking about
this to make any sort of
call to congress to revisit an aunt once
american troops are out of afghanistan
well the president certainly supports uh
revisiting revising taking a look at the
aunf we put out a statement several
weeks ago about that
um that remains the case that remains
his point of view and we look forward to
working with leaders in congress to do
exactly that
he's not like tying the truth withdrawal
to a new aums no
he's not tying the troop withdrawal but
he is uh something that is something he
would like to see move forward
yeah go ahead david thanks a couple
questions one just
closing the loop on something you said
in afghanistan um
when you were a state department uh
spokeswoman you frequently talked about
the importance of conditions based
withdrawals because
otherwise the message to the taliban
would be
way to south and once we're gone they
have
free reign over the country um
i don't think i've heard in the answers
so far
what the taliban is supposed to think
about this i mean if i was
them i think i want to take the summer
off and wait until september 11th
and why go ahead and negotiate an
agreement that would
limit them if the us is going to leave
anyway
well first i i would say that we have an
expectation
that the taliban is going to abide by
their commitments um
and that they are not going to allow
afghanistan to become a pariah state
um that's our view that's also in their
interest in our view
in terms of conditions based withdrawal
we've been as you know david you've
covered this
for 20 years i would say not not to age
you you are young at heart
um but you know the president um
has also been involved in the
discussions and debates about what to do
at afghanistan for that period of time
as you all know and his view is that um
you know when you talk about a
conditions-based withdrawal it punts it
down the road we will never leave
what conditions would we be required to
leave how by
how long what is it what does that mean
what's the additional cost
these are all the factors in his mind
and as you look back at recent history
you know in back in 2014 which seems
recent back when i was at the state
department i should say
nato allies issued a declaration
affirming that afghan security forces
which you well remember
would have full responsibility of their
country's security by the end of the
year
that was seven years ago and the
president just believes that we can't
have american troops as bargaining chips
now is the time to get out so in terms
of the taliban's role
uh again we believe diplomacy is the
right path forward
we believe that it is not in their
interest for afghanistan to become
a pariah state that they should hold to
their commitments
of preventing al qaeda of not allowing
al qaeda i should say
to gain a stronghold or a safe haven in
afghanistan
to remain committed to some of the
progress that we have seen
and we will have to see if that happens
so you've narrowed the american
objective
to keeping a terrorist group from being
able to launch when you've made a good
point they could launch
an attack from many other places back in
2011
president obama still was using a
broader set he said
we had to build afghan capacity protect
population centers
blunt and degrade the taliban capacity
those are no longer american objectors
it sounds like
well i think it's important to go back
to what our objectives were
when we went into afghanistan 20 years
almost 20 years ago
and those were to disrupt terrorists
seeking to use
afghanistan as a safe haven we feel we
have done that
it was to deliver justice to those who
attacked us we feel we have done that
and there has certainly been and that's
why i referenced uh
the the nate the declaration by nato
allies
a desire to to to transfer over
uh control and leadership to the afghan
security forces we've also seen
over the last seven years uh that that
is not gone as
would have been predicted in 2014 so i
would say the way the president views it
and you know his own history on this and
it has been well
publicized and published that he opposed
the surge uh back 10 years ago
um and he was vocal about that in the
appropriate manner at the
at that time uh now he is president now
we are 10 years later
now we are looking at the circumstances
on the grounds we are looking at what's
in our national interests we are looking
at
where we actually see threats around the
world but also opportunity
and part of his assessment as
commander-in-chief is that having a
presence there is not in our interests
i want a wrong question for you you've
repeatedly said in the past couple of
days
you're not going to engage in
speculation about what happened last
weekend
i can't recall a recent time when the
u.s has had such
an absence of public curiosity about
what led to a major explosion in a major
foreign site
what's behind your reluctance to discuss
what happened who did it what its
implications could be for american
policy
well public curiosity should not be
mistaken for
curiosity in general david as you know
um
but i i will say um you know we're just
not going to speculate
on the origin uh our focus is on
looking for a diplomatic path forward
with iran that's where we feel we can
have a role
and where we feel we can constructively
move things forward
even though those are indirect
negotiations for the iranians that they
are
going to pull back from those
negotiations because that do you think
they're moving ahead we have not heard
been given an indication that they don't
plan to attend
or i should say let me make it more
positive we our understanding is they
plan to attend um
tomorrow uh we are we are also very
open-eyed about how this will be a long
process
it's happening through indirect
discussions but we still feel that it is
a step forward
okay go ahead brittany go ahead thanks
jen uh on the campaign trail then can it
brought in it's a follow-up on to bring
this question
sure policing report uh promised
investment was 300 million
into local police departments and
municipalities trying to see if they
would either diversify
their precincts whatever they could do
to make um reduce police brutality in
their localities given what's been
happening over the last
year but even just this last couple of
weeks as the white house and this
president fighting still maintain that
that is the best
use of that 300 million dollars
investments giving money essentially to
the police department to
self-regulate well i will say i know
this didn't receive
um a lot of attention but in our
discretionary guidance
it was consistent with this and maybe
this is what you're asking about but we
could get you the more details too or
for others who are interested
um you know he has been clear and he
continues to believe to answer your
question
that giving police departments the
resources they need
to implement meaningful reforms and
conditioning federal daughter
dollars on completing those reforms is
is the appropriate and effective
step and the discretionary guidance does
exactly that it provides funds with
specific requirements
like ensuring law enforcement agencies
mirror the diversity of the communities
they serve
it also invests in federal programs that
hold police accountable through pattern
and practice investigations and the
enforcement of consent decrees now
that's just
a funding component right there are also
reforms that the president feels
need to be put in place and the george
floyd act certainly has a number of
those reforms and
and steps that he supports and he is uh
eager for congress to move forward on
and i know there's lots on your
legislative plate you know
infrastructure and
many other things are there folks in the
back making calls to congress just on
george floyd on the storage void bill
kind of working all the levers in order
to get that through obviously it's going
to face an uphill battle
in the walk center that we have now uh
certainly we we are very engaged
in having discussions with a range of
members on the george floyd bill and
moving it forward
and we are certainly encouraged by
discussions that are ongoing
by members of congress and ultimately it
will be up to them to determine
how they can negotiate and come to
conclusion on a package that there can
be enough
support to move forward and send to the
president's desk there's one
other on the vice president um will she
be giving a press conference either
right before right after her trip too is
it mexico and
guatemala that's a good question i don't
know that the the final format of this
trip has been scheduled
quite yet um but i can see if they have
any more details on the planning
two of those three northern triangle
countries actually do not have
us ambassador to them they have charged
affairs but they do not have investors
is there any more
guidance you can give us on when those
critical roles will be built or at least
with this
name she couldn't fill in those roles
well i i would say probably won't put
out lists of names
we'll probably put out the nominees once
the decision because that would be a
form of torture for the people who are
on those
lists in some way but um we are moving
forward
starting to make the president starting
to make some decisions on career
ambassadors
to a range of posts um i hopefully will
have some more on that soon
but i'm not sure if they're in those re
in that region but
uh he's he's uh he's starting to
consider a range of qualified
individuals so hopefully we'll have more
soon
go ahead i have two questions for you
17 house democrats said earlier this
week that they won't support
any tax legislation or the component of
the infrastructure plan that the
president proposed
unless it does away with the ten
thousand dollar salt cap
i wanted to see if that's something the
administration would consider
well i would say first we welcome ideas
we welcome proposals from a range of
members and many of them have been
quite vocal about their views on the
salt deduction as well so we're familiar
with them
uh there's a meeting later this
afternoon with ron clayne
and steve roshetti i think with some of
these members and others there's a range
of topics they'll discuss
that are of interest to them and i'm
sure they will i would guess they would
raise this
uh we're also interested in proposals on
how to pay for
a package and as you know uh the salt
deduction
would not be a revenue raiser so they
may come with proposals and ideas on
that as well but we're certainly
happy to hear more from them on the
impact and why they think this is so
important to their states and
communities
and i wanted to ask about the global
minimum tax that the president has
proposed
at 21 in the global negotiations we're
already seeing some pushback from
lawmakers in europe saying that number
is too high and i wanted to see what the
administration plans to do to negotiate
to get
countries around the world on board with
a number or the number who's proposed or
a higher number than it already is well
i certainly think those negotiations
will happen out of the treasury
department um the reason the global
minimum tax was proposed was because
the administration secretary yell and
others felt it was important to
end the race to the bottom on tax rates
in countries and
this would be a way to do that um in her
view and their
view but in terms of a discussion about
alternate rates
i would certainly send you to them for
uh more of a bottom line of where
they're willing to go
and um the other question is about the
bureau of land management
we have reporting that president biden
is considering tracy
stone manning a senior advisor for
conservation policy at the national
wildlife federation to lead the bureau
could you confirm that i don't have any
personnel announcements to make
um we i don't expect we will have any to
make uh on this but i will
check and see if there's more to report
to you sure hi
isaac um so just to follow up a little
bit more on the vice president's meeting
by the northern triangle
can you just help us figure out how that
fits in the sequencing
of the role that she is playing what the
purpose of today's meeting was and then
sort of what the next steps forward from
it would be
coming out of it well i think you know a
couple of things
one uh we've seen um the vice president
has obviously
also had a number of internal meetings
uh on these issues
with internal leaders and team members
we don't always read those meetings out
but those are part of
the discussion as well certainly she she
also spoke directly with the presidents
of mexico
and guatemala recently and i believe we
read out those calls and we made an
announcement about
steps we were taking or steps these
countries were taking through
discussions with us to
increase staffing and personnel and
monitoring at the borders to reduce the
number of migrants who are coming
to our border so in terms of the
sequencing part of the sequencing is
internal discussions with experts
whether that is the secretary of
homeland security the secretary of
health and human services
uh others who are working at the nsc to
determine what the right path forward is
with the northern triangle
she leads a number of those
conversations gets feedback from
our special envoy ricardo zuniga and
others who have been working on these
issues for some time
she's also had a number of calls
directly with presidents in the region i
expect she'll have more of those to
discuss
negotiations and diplomatic
conversations even
even in advance of traveling and then
she will make a trip as she
announced this morning uh and while i
don't think she announced the timing of
it
uh that would certainly be another step
in the sequence so this is all just
still
sorting out what the right path forward
is rather than making determination okay
this is what we're gonna do well
we announced just two days ago i believe
two days three days ago
um some steps that were being taken in
coordination and through discussion with
these countries to
ensure that immigration migration i
should say a regular migration
was being addressed as more of a
hemispheric issue and that meant
uh you know working with these countries
to put in place
measures to discourage migration that's
a step but
it will be discussions internally policy
decisions that's typically how it works
calls with these leaders announcements
about progress made it will be ongoing i
wouldn't expect it will be a process and
nothing happens till the end
this is an ongoing process and we'll
make announcements i'm sure she will as
the developments are concluded the
president given her
uh any directives from what's coming
back so far
to guide were the next conversations
that
she would be having or the next steps
she'd be taking and
leading this effort well the president
and the vice president see each other
quite regularly
she's in many of the meetings when she's
in town almost all of them
that the president is in as well so i
would say it's more of a discussion with
others who are leading and running
points on these issues and one other
thing that there's a markup today about
dc statehood
um given the political realities around
what would
need to happen for dc state of bill to
get through the senate
filibuster would almost certainly need
to be gone is this something that
president biden is going to be pursuing
at this point
at dc state or is he just sort of
leaving it as
a thing that he supports but is not
going to be on his priority list
well he supports it and in his
conversations of which there are many as
is evidenced by the last few days
a range of topics and issues come up and
he certainly expresses his support and
ultimately it's up to congress to pass
legislation and send it to his desk
he's not going to prioritize it and say
i want this bill on my desk
i i would say he he supports it so he'd
be happy to sign it but in terms of the
rank priorities i'm not going to get
into a situation of doing that but
it's something he supports he's conveyed
that to congress and uh he certainly
supports efforts to move it forward go
ahead in the back hi jen thank you very
much uh follow
up on the afghanistan and then i have
another one the climate summit
you were talking about the diplomatic
presence in afghanistan
after the withdrawal do you expect the
united states will have an ambassador
uh in afghanistan before the troops
leave
do you mean to just to understand your
question do we expect we will maintain
or we will nominate an ambassador
exactly
well our intention is to maintain a
presence to secure a diplomatic presence
there and
which was kind of a different question
but so i don't have a timeline on that
but certainly
given we will have a diplomatic presence
i expect we would have an ambassador at
some point for nominee
about the climate segment how are the
discussions
with brazil uh going uh is president
biden prepared prepare
to sign a bilateral climate deal
with brazil next week during the the
summit
or would he like to see more commitment
uh from brazil on defense station
before making a deal well i don't know
that i would see
the climate summit as a bilateral
deal-making
venue it is we've invited about 40
global leaders
um in terms of the format and the
details i think they'll
they will many will be presenting their
own plans for reaching
the goals as set out by global climate
climate i should say objectives i think
that's a big part of the format there
are not going to be bilateral meetings
as a part of this summit
um so i wouldn't see it through that
prism it's an incredibly important forum
to bring global leaders including
brazil the united states many others
together to discuss what the president
feels is one of the biggest crises we
face
but our position on brazil has been
clear since the beginning
we believe brazil is a key partner in
confronting climate issues climate
solutions will of course need brazil's
action
and leadership we fully respect brazil's
sovereignty and
appreciate the chance to participate in
constructive conversations on how we can
work
together we do want to see a clear
commitment to ending illegal
deforestation
tangible steps to increase effective
enforcement of illegal deforestation
and a political signal that illegal
deforestation and encroachment will not
be tolerated and we believe it's
realistic for brazil to achieve a real
decrease in deforestation
by the end of the 2021 fire season so we
continue to recognize that conservation
and sustainable economic growth can go
hand in hand and
certainly that's our expectation for
brazil what could be a clear commitment
and also uh will president by the
pressure
the brazilian president bolsonaro
personally during the
summit well again it's not up there's
not bilateral meetings so
i i can't i can't i can't i don't have
any outline of what the president's
remarks will look like but i would
expect that he will
talk more broadly about the need for the
global community to address
the threat of the climate crisis can i
just ask one last question about
the pandemic because the white house
culver team had a conversation with the
brazilian health minister
brazil as you know now is the epicenter
of this pandemic
and uh dr fudge said a couple of weeks
ago that
he was waiting for this conversation to
see other ways that the united states
could be more helpful
so is the united states providing
additional help
uh to brazil like sending oxygen
or sedatives for intubation for example
there are lack of all these things in
brazil right now sure
uh i would have to check i would say
that we of course as you know are
contributing a significant amount of
funding through kovacs uh
i know there are requests from around
the world for a range of tools and
resources i can check if there's
anything
that's going to brazil more specifically
oh yes oh yeah can i do owen first and
then i'll come right back to you okay go
ahead on
thank you back to title 10 if i may uh
so today as you well know the pride
administration at hhs
started the reversal of the trump
administration's ban
on abortion referrals at title 10 family
planning clinics
so my first question why does the biden
administration
insist that pro-life americans pay for
abortions and violate their conscience
well first that's not an accurate
depiction of what happens so let me
and i know we want to be accurate around
here none of the funds appropriated
under this title shall be used in
programs where abortion is a method of
family
planning that is written into the public
health service act and it specifically
states that indirect subsidies money
that's fungible that can't be traced
that is not how it works that is the law
so i'm stating what the law is and how
it is implemented legally by these
organizations and the reason i though
since you gave me the opportunity
the reason why the president took these
steps is because
he believes that advancing equity for
all including people of color and others
who have been
historically underserved marginalized
and adversely affected by persistent
poverty
and inequality can be helped by these
actions and by focusing on advancing
equity in the title 10 program we can
create opportunities for the improvement
of
communities that have been historically
underserved which benefits
everyone that's how these fundings are
used in communities you talk about
equity if i may interrupt
how is it equity how is it fighting
systemic racism when
abortion we well know disproportionately
affects minority
children again funding cannot be used
from this
for abortion but access to health care
uh access to health care in communities
and communities that have been
marginalized
underserved adversely affected by
persistent poverty is always going to be
something
the president fights for okay i think
i've answered your question alex go
ahead
on afghanistan did president biden
consult any of his predecessors on his
decision to withdraw
he did talk to some of his predecessors
uh let me see if i can get you more of a
readout of that he will talk a bit about
that in his speech as well that starts
in
39 minutes i don't know if you saw this
but the
afghan president tweeted that he spoke
with uh president
he did and that was still going on when
i came out here so we will get you
a readout of that let me just also
because you kind of
you prompted me that we have done a lot
of outreach which i think would be
interesting to you in your reporting
in the last 36 hours uh to inform
members of congress allies partners in
regional countries
that includes calls not all with the
president although he has made a number
of calls
but from senior officials to nearly 50
members of congress 44 countries
nato the eu and the un uh
these consultations and conversations
are continuing but just to give you a
sense of how much engagement outreach
we've done to date
okay thanks everyone